[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today what's
going on
Kylie hi there thanks for taking my call
you bet what's going on okay so my
husband and I are in a situation um so
right now we are just not making end
meet meet we're in the negative every
month and I'm trying to figure out if we
I'll bankrupt or if we I don't we don't
see another way so we're just trying to
figure that out right now so the bills
that you have we're not paying the bills
that we have and I'm assuming there's
debt as well right yeah so we have that
we can so we we're paying our bills we
we're not behind on like food house
electricity any of our we're we're doing
the taking care of ourselves and you're
paying minimums on the debt as well yes
okay yep so can you kind of list out the
debt for us yes so we have um 880,000 in
student debt okay which we're we we're
not paying on and I'm in school so it's
all deferred um not that do exist but
are you still ACR hold on are you still
ACR student loan debt um I think
technically it opens up this weekend
right no I mean you said you're still in
school so I'm saying are you still
continuing to take Lo to I am getting y
girl we gonna talk about that we're
we'll talk about that let's take it one
thing at a time though so so far we've
got the 80,000 in student loans what
else yes um and we have 30,000 in
personal loan there's 25 personal loan
and then um another 5,000 is credit
cards okay and so you're in school are
you working at all while you're in
school I I work um parttime from home we
have four kids and we homeschool oh wow
parttime from home four kids you're
homeschooling what are you earning
working part-time from home um I bring
home around 21,000 a year okay and what
is your husband earning um he is making
right now he just got a new job in his
new degree field um and he's only making
36,000 a year what is he
doing he's doing software support so he
went and like got his it and coding
stuff and he couldn't find a better
job yet when I hear what the coders are
pulling in in this building it makes me
wish I'd gone to coding school that's
what we
also thought but I mean we would take
any leads
okay here's when you tell me your income
my brain goes to the average income the
median income in America and I I'm
always striving to to get people at
least to the median all right which is
around 67,000 just to know like all
right I'm in the game so I really want
that to be your goal very very quickly
um you got $15,000 in debt um if we want
to make this needle move the secret
sauce here is getting the income up and
running like
cranking
and the thing that I the thing that I
want you to understand is you're you
can't solve a problem while
simultaneously creating it and right now
you're still adding to the debt and so
any movement that you make forward is
going to feel futile so what I want to
do is stop the bleeding and so you're
going you're going to school now what's
the endgame of this um so I'm in my
Master's to be a licensed counselor okay
how much time is left and how much more
money is being added to this bill um how
much time is left like three four years
I'm doing very part-time and I honestly
don't even know the end like probably at
least another 50 can I say something
really hard don't do
that can I say it John I'm I'm I dude I
I've got a PhD and counseling I'm going
tell you don't do it I was a I was a
graduate school Professor here's why I'm
telling you that 50,000 on top of the
other 80 for a clinical mental health
counseling degree is going to be a
nightmare to pay off and dude I was a
graduate school Professor I need more
counselors out there I want people to go
to graduate school and get their
counseling degrees here's the deal
you're broke y'all can't afford this and
you got four kids yeah you have to make
some radical hard hard choices
like we want the idea of homeschooling
all four of our kids maybe they got to
go to public school for a couple years
where we clean up the mess that the
adults in the house made my husband
really wants to be a coder but he can
make about that much money being an
assistant manager at McDonald's right
now
he's going to go find a job and a second
one too y'all are in a situation and I
think you want to have I want to be a
licensed therapist dude I want that so
bad for you we want a homeschooler kids
I so badly want that for you want him to
be a coder because they keep saying
we're going to make $200,000 I want that
for him too but the reality is those
things aren't real right now what is
real is y'all can't breathe because um
you owe so much money and let me tell
you this and you probably learned this
in your grad school classes already your
children absorb the the tension in your
home and if Mom and Dad can't pay bills
the mom and dad are struggling with each
other and those kids are absorbing that
every second of every
day see what I'm saying and so sometimes
it's a Dream Deferred several times in
my second doctoral program I had to quit
I took off a semester because I had to
take care of things at home I had to
take care of things with me and my wife
and so it may be the time and there's
going to be a state school that I
promise you can get a great clinical
master's degree that's going to be
infinitely cheaper than what you're
doing MH and you'll be able to pay cash
as you go I know it's hard but you and
your husband aren't being you aren't
dealing with reality and and I don't
mean that like you're not living on the
moon yall just don't make enough money
and you want to do this and you want to
do this you want to do this um if you
put all four of your kids in public
school on Monday and you went to work
full-time you instantly are able to
breathe
instantly and if he says three of them
are too young for school but yeah okay
but you know you get you get the sense
of what I'm saying right um and and or
you reach out to somebody at local
church and you get some help or you take
your part-time job and and your you look
at your husband say you're making 36
Grand you were trying to get off the
ground with this great and I know you
want to be around with all four kids
great but we have to have more money
right now yeah there is going to be a
sacrifice there's going to be way
there's not a sacrifice there's going to
be a sacrifice there's going to be a
trade and that's based on what you say
the priority is I mean we can say this
is a money show and this you know John's
going to speak to the other side of it
but we're always going to
prioritize what gets you feeling peace
in feeling freedom first and I think a
lot of times people think oh like
probably in your mind you're like oh
I'll get my degree I'll be able to earn
more money and that was the path but
then you pull back and you're like wait
a second this is just creating more like
frustration more debt more chaos and
when that happens you do have to stop
and regroup and go okay what was the
priority again what was the thing
because it can't everything can't be A1
if everything's A1 then you start going
crazy yeah and so something something
goes on the chopping block and that's
the really really hard part of this
conversation uh not just for you Kylie
but for so many folks listening thank
you for the call because I think just by
you sharing your story it provides
Clarity for a lot of people cuz John
you're so right you have to make hard
choices very rarely in life do you get
to just get all of it at once well and
you mentioned something goes on the
chopping block and if you don't want it
to be your degree it doesn't want you
don't want to be your career dream it
will be your marriage yeah it will be
your relationship with your kids yeah
it'll be your peace something has to pay
the piper and so let it be the adults in
the house that is such a good word uh
yeah you got to make the sacrifice and
you know what sometimes I don't like the
word sacrifice John I like to call it a
trade cuz it's really what are you
trading what are you getting in return
and when you say it like that it has I
don't know a better ring to it